we have truly horrific news to start
with today the worst mass shooting in
modern American history was in the early
hours Eastern Time today around 10:00
p.m. Pacific time last night Sunday
night in Las Vegas Nevada where a gunman
opened fire this was at an outdoor
country music festival sort of alongside
the Mandalay Bay
Hotel and even though this was not a
crowd that was at Mandalay Bay it was
close enough to Mandalay Bay that the
gunman was actually on the 32nd floor of
the Mandalay Bay Hotel in Las Vegas and
so far and the numbers have already
shifted drastically over the last four
or five hours over 50 killed is the
number that we have and more than 400
injured so far and there were numerous
off-duty police officers who were
believed to be among the dead and the
injured and the gunman has been
identified and is no longer alive the
gunman identified a 64 year-old Steven
paddock of Mesquite Nevada he was found
dead reportedly when SWAT entered his
hotel of an apparent suicide although
the details are still unclear multiple
weapons were found in the shooters hotel
room these shooters brother was
interviewed by the media and said he was
not aware of the shooter having at the
types of weapons that were reportedly
used in this event which include sort of
rapid-fire automatic firearms and police
used explosives even to get into the
hotel room of the shooter here a totally
chaotic totally terrifying and reports
of just endless people dropping dead or
injured in a crowd and it can be really
difficult to accurately assess how long
this lasted there are some eyewitnesses
who say this was not a quick event this
was something like 7 to 10 minutes and
of course we know that particularly in
these situations
eyewitness testimony can really be off
in terms of how long something went on
needless to say from the video we have
it was clearly bad police shut down the
area they urged the public to stay away
flights in and out of McCarran Airport
in Los Angeles were temporarily halted
here
just 15 seconds of audio of what the
sounded like
[Applause]
now that noise tells us that this
incident is directly related to the
types of firearms and ammunition that
the shooter had right and I'm not
talking about gun laws in this sort of
general sense of background checks or
anything like that the size of magazines
for automatic type weapons that makes a
difference this is not what someone
would be able to do these are not the
sounds of fire that you would hear if
someone had access only to the types of
firearms that were available when the
Second Amendment was written and when
people hear that gunfire how can you say
that gun laws don't make any difference
right if it were harder for this guy to
get high-capacity firearms that could be
fired at this rate of fire would he have
done just as much damage from the 32nd
floor of a hotel with a handgun you hear
this meme from the pro-gun right very
often guns don't kill people people kill
people well yes that's true
and people can kill other people far
more easily when they have access to
firearms that have that rate of fire
what about knives right you always hear
hey listen even if there weren't knives
guns available people would just do the
exact same thing except with knives this
guy from the 32nd floor of a hotel room
was going to kill 50-plus people and
injure over 400 with knives what was he
gonna toss the knives out the window and
drop them on the victims so this is as
good a time as any to talk about the gun
control aspect of this you need to be
aware that you're politicizing a tragedy
is a line that is used by the right when
they don't want to have serious
conversations it's a shut down loud line
so the right says the left whenever they
don't want to have a talk what don't
want to talk about a particular issue
the left will say that's an offensive
question to be asking right that's the
criticism from the
right of the left to shut down debate
the right has their own version of that
right the right has their own version of
all forms of political correctness they
criticize the left of this is not the
time to politicize a national tragedy
they say it on climate change after
hurricanes and they say it on gun
legislation after there are mass
shooting incidents don't fall for it
okay say the politics relate to what
took place here now the things we don't
yet know right the motive if any
according to the according to police
police aren't yet aware of what the
belief system was of this individual
there it's been designated not connected
to international terrorism hard to deny
that this is an act of domestic terror
the suspects history is being looked at
including whether he had prior
communications with police police have
already said this is not an entity along
with a woman who was allegedly in the
crowd telling people that they were
going to die and appears to have been
connected to the incident police have
said these were not known entities to us
the individual the shooter lived at a 55
plus a sort of retirement community and
people there have been interviewed and
they said we couldn't really tell you
anything that was out of the ordinary
about this individual so we will
hopefully eventually find out what the
circumstances were the immediate
speculation has been pretty unhelpful on
both sides there are some who say listen
this was a country music concert this
guy is a violent liberal and he knew at
a country show there would be
conservative so that's why he attacked
that then there's the demographic
argument which is 64 year old white men
who have guns from a town of 18,000 it
named Mesquite Nevada are probably
right-wingers not left wingers we don't
know we don't know and the entire
speculation that is in the round they're
in it within that spectrum or outside of
it not helpful right now I'm going to be
in Las Vegas in a couple of weeks I'm
anticipating a very different security
situation and probably a different just
general atmosphere around these massive
hotel casino complexes and rightly so
after this incident